ja Deutschland fürchtet den Winter und
die Energiekrise die löst erneut die
Debatte um die AKWs aus lenken die
Grünen jetzt doch ein die
Vizepräsidentin des Deutschen
Bundestages und Grünen Politikerin
Katrin Göring-Eckardt die schwurbild in
der ARD-Talkshow Anne Will ganz schön
rum
wir brauchen keine Laufzeitverlängerung
weil das was die Atomkraftwerke leisten
könnten nicht relevant ist für das
Problem was wir in diesem Winter haben
wir haben einen sonderproblem über das
muss man sprechen und diese
sonderprobleme ist in Bayern entstanden
weil auf der einen Seite Horst Seehofer
gesagt hat Leitungen möchte ich nicht
bauen weil er sich nicht mit seinen
Bürgerinitiativen überwerfen wollte
viel Gerede also um die bösen Bayern
dabei unterschlägt die Grünen
Politikerin viele genau dieser
Bürgerinitiativen werden von grünen
Lokalpolitikern gepusht
und in München sprechen sich gerade
Grüne und SPD für eine Verlängerung von
Isa 2 um 6 Monate aus eine
Laufzeitverlängerung wird es nicht geben
die Frage ist wie gehen wir mit diesem
sonderproblem um und dieses
sonderproblem kann heißen dass diese
Brennstäbe noch ausgebrannt werden
müssen damit man in also streckbetrieb
damit man damit man in Bayern über die
Runden kommt das heißt nicht das heißt
übrigens nirgendwo mehr dass wir einfach
so weitermachen können wie in der
Vergangenheit also halten wir noch mal
für sie fest Göring-Eckardt will keinen
steckbetrieb mit AKWs keine
Laufzeitverlängerung also für die
Atomenergie doch dann auf einmal die
Kehrtwende gering-eckardt erklärt sich
als nächste grünen Politikerin bereit
AKWs doch am Netz zu lassen
ich will das natürlich ein bisschen
konkreter haben das heißt dass dieser
sie lassen einen streckbetrieb zu das
heißt wenn es dazu kommt dass wir eine
wirkliche Notsituation haben dass
Krankenhäuser nicht mehr arbeiten können
wenn eine solche Notsituation eintritt
dann müssen wir darüber reden was mit
den Brennstäben ist
und darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit
unserer Reporterin Annika rasch annika
ist das was Kathrin gehring-eckardt
jetzt sagt die grüne Kehrtwende
fakt ist die Grünen denken um und das
Entscheidende ist nicht was die Grünen
sagen sondern was sie nicht sagen und
das Wort heißt nein sie sagen also nicht
Nein zur
Laufzeitverlängerung sondern sagen man
müsste sich diese Fakten einmal ansehen
das war bis vor kurzem ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich jetzt ist es eigentlich
ziemlich wahrscheinlich denn auch
Harbeck hatte bis vor kurzem gesagt eine
Laufzeitverlängerung sei vom Tisch jetzt
sieht es schon ganz anders aus und auch
Außenministerin baerbock hat mit meinem
Kollegen Paul ronsheimer gesprochen und
da schien es auch gar nicht mehr so
unwahrscheinlich
in so schwierigen Entscheidungsprozessen
ist es immer wichtig dass man auch
faktengrundlagen jeden Schritt geht ja
sind ja nicht ohne Grund aus der
Atomkraft in Deutschland ausgestiegen
jetzt sind wir in einer Notsituation wo
wir uns alles noch mal anschauen
deswegen hat Robert Habeck mit der
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke ja
zusammen bereits einen ersten Test
gemacht ob es helfen würde mit Blick auf
Atomkraftwerke Annika immer
widersprechen die Grünen also von
besonders schweren Zeiten werden aber
nie konkret was sind denn besonders
schwere Zeiten
ja Sandra da hast du recht sie werden da
nicht ganz konkret die Grünen haben sich
da auch noch nicht wirklich festgelegt
Göring-Eckardt hat eben gestern gesagt
dass das praktisch dass diese besonders
schweren Zeiten dann eintreten wenn
Krankenhäuser nicht mehr so richtig
arbeiten können die Grünen Spitze
baerbock und Harbeck sehen das aber
etwas anders die sagen diese
Notsituation ist jetzt schon da und
diese Notsituation gibt es jetzt auch
schon das Gas ist knapp und Putin ist
und berechenbar und das kriegen jetzt
auch die Grünen zu spüren vielen Dank
Annika rasch